I've got 10 cards here I'm going to
shuffle them up they're just one to ten
or eight to ten you can see there look a
2-part
ten apart nine not seven four so I'm
just going to shuffle them up and then
they lay them out our calories it looks
like you've got the world's smallest
hands these are normal sized cards aunt
as a tiny person I'm going to lay these
out
I'll count along when I lay them out and
I win if the position matches its value
which means if ace comes out first I win
if if the four comes out fourth I win
okay now what's the chance of me winning
this game as are my likely to get a
match that's the question am I likely to
can match do you think it's likely do
you think it's unlikely do you think
it's greater than 50% do you think it's
less than 50% 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ah 10 so
I got no match now is that what you
expected did you expect me to get no
match well actually I think I was quite
unlucky there to get no match because
the probability of having no match is
37% so poverty of getting one match
winning the game would have been 63% so
it's actually more likely to win over
fifty Cent not a huge amount over 50% so
it can go wrong okay so you can lose
this game if you're especially unlucky
good yeah like me if you're unlucky like
me you might lose this game but I use 10
cards here and the probability of
winning with 10 cards is 63% do you
think then if I had 100 cards am I more
likely to get a match or less likely to
get a match well I can tell you it's
still 63% it doesn't matter doesn't
matter how many cards you have it's a
constant it's going to be 63% no matter
how many cards you have or if it's to go
okay you caught me out there I was going
to get to that I was going to get to
that it's 63% if you use 4 or more cards
so
pretty much any game okay so you don't
again that uses three and two and one is
not
63% but hey four or more and you will
always get 63% chance of winning that's
a that's a constant so the way you solve
this problem
it's about matches getting a match or
not getting a match and these things
where you are not looking for a match is
called as an arrangement at the
arrangement which is such fun to say so
we're going to get the range so let's do
that so if you're mixing up cards or any
objects like that
that's called a permutation or you might
call it an arrangement maybe that's a
word you would use if I had say five
things
let's do five dots I have five dots here
and then I could arrange them in any way
I'm going to do that with arrows to show
that you know one becomes two two
becomes three let's say three becomes
five say four goes across to four and
five becomes one like that so you can
have any kind of scramble like that so
how many ways can you scramble those
objects well that's n factorial in
general so there are n factorial ways
you can scramble up and objects number
where number of permutations n factorial
now a derangement is a permutation that
has no fixed points now this is not a
derangement look for went to four it's
fixed it didn't change that's not a
derangement so the arrangement is
something like that but there are no
fixed point so if I did the same sort of
idea and drawn in a derangement would
mean yeah something like this maybe like
that and maybe it's something down there
there you go
that would be a valid arrangement and
the symbol for derangement so how many
derangements are there so it's a subset
of permutations so there's fewer and the
number of arrangements has this symbol
it's escalation mark n it's like a
backwards factorials now how many of
these are their well there's a formula
for that the number of the arrangements
is approximately the number of
presentations divided by e ah surprise e
oh where did that come from
surprise e there he is and that in fact
is a very accurate formula in fact SI
approximately just take the nearest
integer round up or round down and
you're done
that's how many arrangements there are
boom straightaway so if I'm interested
in the probability of losing this game
I'm looking in I'm looking at the
probability of no fixed points so as I'm
looking for the number of the
arrangements so it's probability of no
fixed points and you foul mother didn't
do that what are no fixed points this
wasn't this was a derangement I
accidentally had a derangement I didn't
plan it so I just went and saw what
happened so we thought you lost but
you're a genius well I didn't plan it
but it works out for this video so if
you want to find the probability of no
fixed points it's how many Arrangements
we have so this is equal to number of
derangement divided by the total number
of ways I could have scrambled up those
n objects which is the total number of
permutations so this is the probability
of no fixed points you're taking all
these arrangements and dividing by all
the possible permutations and we have a
formula for that and so this is going to
be approximately 1 over e which is going
to be not 0.37 which is why it's 37% to
get a derangement or 63% to get a match
which is the opposite question so one of
the classic versions of this same
problem is called the secretary problem
so imagine having a secretary and that
person's got letters to various people
and they've got envelopes for those same
people so you need to put the letters in
the right envelopes so that secretary
they're looking at their watch they're
trying to get out the door right so
they're just quickly shoving in letters
into envelopes what's the probability
that at least one letter goes to the
right person
ends up in the right envelope and that's
going to be 63% another version of the
same problem is the hat problem hat
checking problem this sounds a bit
old-fashioned to me sounds a bit
Edwardian which is you go to the theater
and people check their hats at the
cloakroom
that sounds very old-fashioned but they
put them in boxes and then they just
give them out back to people without
thinking so again what's the probability
that someone gets their hat back at 63%
again it's sort of our various versions
of the same question would we be using
the same style of mathematics if we
started wanting to know what's the
probability of two people getting their
hat back or 10 people or will be started
using other mathematical weapons to
figure that out yes so to answer the
question of exactly two people something
like that it's harder what I've actually
done here is worked out the probability
that no one gets the correct match and
that's quite an easy thing to solve once
you start asking questions about these
people did so many people didn't so many
people did and it gets more complicated
to work out so this formula I've just
given you seems to come out of nowhere I
want to show you where that formula
comes from but this is going to be for
the dedicated viewer I think it's not a
simple proof but I think it's doable but
we're going to try all right let's let's
see where that formula came from so
imagine having all the possible
permutations right it's the set of all
possible permutations I'm actually going
to draw a Venn diagram so these are all
the possible permutations that you can
have which means there are